i remember those early days of when the
pandemic started i was just sitting down
it was late january or early february
2020 and i just was laying out
all of the evidence just as i that i
could collect trying to say make sense
of where does this come from and it's
just it was just logic i mean i i i it
was all the things that jon stewart said
which in some you know overly wordy form
were all at that time on my website like
what are the odds of
having this this outbreak of a bad
coronavirus more than a thousand miles
away from where these bats have their
natural habitat
where they have the this largest
collection of these bad coronaviruses in
the world and they're doing all these
very aggressive
research projects to make them more
aggressive and then you have the
outbreak of a virus that's that's primed
for a human to human transmission
um
it was just logic was my first step and
i you know kept gathering uh gathering
the the information
but jon stewart distilled that in a way
that just everybody got and i think that
like i loved it and i just think that
there's a way of reaching people it's
the reason why i
write science fiction in addition to
thinking and writing about the science
is that we kind of have to reach people
where they are and and i just thought it
was just
there was a lot of depth i thought in i
mean maybe that's
too
self-serving but like in the analysis
but he he captured that
into the
in into those things about it's like the
the whatever the chewy the outbreak of
chewy goodness
near the hershey factory i wonder where
that came from yeah this the humor this
metaphor
also the like sticking with the joke
when the audience is uh
um
in the audience and stephen colbert he
was like resisting it
he was very uncomfortable with it maybe
that was part of the bit i'm not sure
but it didn't look like it
so stephen in that moment kind of
represent the discomfort of the
scientific community i think it's kind
of interesting that whole dynamic and i
think that was a pivotal moment
that just highlights the value of comedy
the value of
like when joe rogan says i'm just a
comedian
i mean that's such a funny thing to say
it's like saying i'm just a podcaster or
i'm just a writer i'm just a
you know
that ability
is so few words
to express what everybody else is
thinking
um it's so refreshing
and i wish the scientific communicators
would do that too
a little humor a little humor i mean
that's why i love uh elon musk very much
so like the way he communicates
is like
us it's it's so refreshing for for a ceo
of a major company several major
companies to just have a sense of humor
and say ridiculous every once in a
while that's so there's something to
that like it shakes up the whole
conversation to where it gives you
freedom to like think publicly if you're
always trying to say the proper thing
you lose the freedom to think to uh to
reason out to be
authentic and genuine when you say when
you allow yourself the freedom to
regularly say stupid
have fun
make fun of yourself
i think you give yourself freedom to
really be a great scientist
honestly i i think scientists have a lot
to learn from comedians
you